hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well Alistair McIntyre
in chapter 14 of after virtue devotes a
lot of discussion to something that he
terms practices and he clarifies that
this is a technical term for him but
it's also meant to connect up with our
ordinary usage of the term so there's
not an exact identity between the two
but you know there's a bit more
robustness to his conception and after
he explains what practices are and what
practices aren't and how they work he
tells us something else that's
particularly important for understanding
how the practices are developed and
properly understood and he clarifies
thereby the relationship between
practices and then what he calls
standards of excellence rules that
partly embody that and the goods that
practices are intended to allow provide
further protect whatever it is that we
want to conceive of here as the
relationship of goods and so we should
begin by talking about something that
he's stressed there's a difference
between what we can call internal goods
to practices and external goods to
practices internal goods are those which
can only be realized with
in the actual practice itself or
analogous that is similar practices
there are certain goods that are
available to a person who has actually
been doing well with this practice of
say playing chess that are not possible
in other circumstances or other
practices except those that are similar
like playing go and you know there's
lots of other examples that we might use
and there could be you know a little bit
more stretchiness of analogy there but
suffice it to say that MacIntyre thinks
that one of the reasons why we engage in
practices is because there are in fact
some goods for human beings and not just
for the people practicing it than
anybody who could potentially enter that
practice and learn it and and work
through it those goods are available for
the people who are involved in that
practice then there are our external
goods and these would be things like
making money or pleasure or social
prestige and these are available in a
number of different ways
they're only contingently connected to
the practice so a great violinist who
has developed her skills over a period
of time and gone way way past the
rule-bound activities of you know
learning to play scales and various keys
and some music theory and now is a
spontaneous but also disciplined player
they may become rich as a result but
they could also become rich by playing
the stock market they could also become
rich by selling you know a particularly
attractive sort of violin shaped candy
where whatever it happens to be we can
come up with all sorts of things but the
goods that are attained that we could
call it the goods of fine musicianship
which are not by the way unique to
violins of course it's debatable whether
you could in fact develop this by say
playing the tambourine or the triangle
but you know a pianist or a guitarist or
a trombonist could certainly do that as
well so now that we've got this notion
of internal and
external goods brought in we want to
think about what else McIntyre says
about practices which is gonna lead us
to standards the other thing that's
really really central to this is that he
tells us that practices are something
that we do their activities and within
them we are engaged in developing and
extending capacities to attain these
goods now that is an often overlooked a
little little throwaway thing but it's
quite important here he says that the
result of what we do in practices is
that human powers to achieve excellence
are systematically extended and this
happens in in two ways one we might say
at the individual level he uses the
example of the child learning to play
chess and as you become better and
better at it you learn to do strategic
thinking within certain ways right you
don't no longer just haphazardly move
the pieces around or try things out you
think start thinking several moves ahead
you start thinking about what might will
my opponent do that is a capacity that
is being extended for that individual
person let's take the violinist as
another example you start playing the
violin you get better at it you move
from the beginner to the intermediate
level you start playing more and more
challenging pieces you engage in
discussions with people who are also
playing those pieces and perhaps are
much better at you about what the piece
means about how the phrasing ought to go
about what's going on with the
instrument itself and you develop your
capacities now this also takes place not
just at an individual to individual
level but over time disciplines that are
associated with practices like say
playing violin become enhanced over time
we learn things we are no longer having
to reinvent the wheel from the very
beginning it doesn't mean that we don't
have to engage in some development and
we can just pick up exactly where other
people have left off no we have to like
catch up to them
but we're able to catch up to them in a
way that's a bit quicker and so this
applies to any real practice it has
development over time with but it can
also have degeneration over time as well
the internal goods provide a Telos a end
a goal a function a purpose to the
practice itself so if somebody is just
moving pieces around on the chess board
and you say well what's going on there
I'm playing chess no you're not playing
chess you're just puttering around what
about somebody who's like
hyper-competitive and their only
interest is in winning and they'd be
willing to cheat to do that they're
playing chess but they're not actually
playing chess well they've lost sight of
what the goal is which is to engage in
this activity not just to win but to win
within the scope of the rules to
exercise your intelligence your
strategic thinking all these other
capacities now this brings us to
standards of excellence which are
absolutely essential to anything that
McIntyre calls a practice and he tells
us some very interesting things about
this he says that a practice involves
standards of excellence and obedience to
rules as well as the achievements of
goods so we've got three closely
connected things there to enter into a
practice is to accept the authority of
those standards and the inadequacy of my
own performance as judged by them it is
to subject my own attitudes choices
preference and tastes to the standards
which I currently and which currently
and partially define the practice so he
says that if you want to excel or you
want to even develop within a practice
you can't just make it up as you go
along you can't just pick and choose
whatever you want to do there are
certain things that you may decide to do
because they work for you at an earlier
intermediate or even beginner stage
which are later gonna be hindrances
they're gonna screw things up for you
prime example is when you're learning a
stringed instrument it is important to
learn how to finger chords properly
if you're sloppy with it and you say I'm
gonna do it my way well then we just
hard to get to the more advanced things
you're not going to be able to do it
properly and we can say similar things
with other practices that have a more
moral tinge to them like the taking care
of households or communities or the
virtues can also be understood in terms
of certain kinds of practices right
so these standards have to be accepted
at least to some degree and he points
out a few important things about this
these these standards can change and
develop over time as a matter of fact
generally that is the case if you look
at you know just for example medicine
the advances that have been made just in
the last century before us and then in
the 20 years of this century are quite
amazing and if you were doing things
like a doctor did in 2000 in many fields
people would look at you and said what's
going on there why haven't you stayed on
top of the newer better standards that
we have for how to do this or how to
understand this or how to prescribe this
so practices do change and develop over
time as a matter of fact that's that's
pretty common to them it doesn't mean
that everything's in flux all the time
but there are important periods we can
say and he also says they're not immune
from criticism as a matter of fact this
is how they develop over time people say
ok these are the current practices maybe
they could be done better you know a
prime example of this in educational
theory that I went through myself as an
educator is you know there are some
people who are still stuck in the
old-fashioned chalk and talk and they're
giving monotone lectures and they put
things on the board and you're just
supposed to copy them when I was a child
I actually had a social studies teacher
whose class is consistent in telling us
to open up the textbook to a particular
page and to begin underlining from line
3 to line 5 that page ending with the
word not and then to write a thing in
the margin
and it was so incredibly stultifying and
then you know that's that's a sort of
old-school teaching method that has
definite if it ever had any utility it's
definitely used it up I think he could
be said to be a poor practitioner of
Education and then you know when I was a
young professor everybody started saying
the era of lecture is over it's all got
to be active education flip the
classroom you know no more chalk and
talk and I actually entitled some of my
first videos on ten years ago dr.
sailors chalk in talk because I wanted
to say no actually there's a point to
having lectures lectures do convey
information when I would try not doing
lectures my students would actually get
upset and ask when are you gonna lecture
you know we don't want all active
education presumably you know something
more about these texts than we do we're
paying for you to tell us something
about it lectures can be engaging so you
know if we think about the lecture
lecturing within education as a
something like a practice it's not
immune from criticism but the criticisms
have to be on point as well criticism
doesn't just mean well we accept you
know there's something wrong and we have
to change become more modern criticisms
have to be subject to good judgment
that's what criticism means by the way
judgment comes from the Greek word curry
taste which means judge like a judge at
a recital or a play or something like
that so criticism has to take place but
the criticism cannot just be on the
basis of something that's external to
the practice like well this is too
expensive or oh you know not everybody
gets pleasure out of this maybe there
are some things that that's not the
criterion for you know or we could take
those in and in a certain way dentistry
for example there's some things that are
going to hurt we can make them hurt less
but that's not the criteria for a good
dentistry you know when you get a crown
or something like that
it's whether that's gonna stay in that's
the biggest criteria and whether it's
going to fit into the rest of your mouth
and
we could say some aesthetic
considerations so these give you some
some ideas and mcintyre says that the
criticism that's ruled out is any sort
of subjectivist or a motiva stan alysus
there has to be something going beyond
mere preferences in practices and so
this is where we get to this this notion
of subjecting he tells us that we cannot
be initiated into a practice without
accepting the authority of the best
standards realized so far he says if I'm
starting to listen to music I do not
accept my own in capacity to judge
incorrectly I'll never learn to hear let
alone to appreciate bartók's last
quartet if I'm starting to play baseball
I don't accept that others know better
then I when to throw a fastball and when
not
I will never learn to appreciate good
pitching let alone to pitch in the realm
of practices the authority of both Goods
and standards operates in such a way as
to rule out all subjectivist and
emotivist analyses of judgment de
gustibus s dis Futon de now that's a
Latin phrase and he's playing around
there because it's usually there's an
own in there you're and it says in
matters of taste we shouldn't have
arguments or we shouldn't dispute with
each other and MacIntyre is saying in
matters of taste yes we should in fact
and those should be framed in terms of
these standards
if we don't subject ourselves to these
standards we will not develop so it's
not just by the way subjecting ourselves
to these standards it's also subjecting
ourselves to others other people who
understand these standards better who
are further along than us so he says it
belongs to the concept of a practice as
I've outlined it that it's goods can
only be achieved by subordinate
subordinating ourselves within the
practice in our relationship to other
practitioners we have to learn to
recognize what is due to whom we have to
be prepared to take whatever self
endangering risks are demanded along the
way and we have to listen carefully to
what we are told about our own
inadequacies and reply with the same
carefulness
or the facts so you know this is not
that we have to subject ourselves
necessarily to every other practitioner
or everyone who has sort of a higher
rank than us I'll give you a prime
example stemming from my own high school
years when I was in high school we had
two main coaches in our phys ed for the
boys and one of them was the football
coach and one of them was the main track
coach and they also coached other things
as well and one of them was a tough but
also you know insightful and and really
thoroughly good guy the other one was
tough but a bully and he bullied his
players and he taught them to cheat and
he valued winning above everything else
and he probably was a pretty unhappy
person in his own life but he certainly
made a lot of other people miserable and
the gym classes were split between these
two different phys ed teachers and
within the one class we actually learned
not just a lot about how to play floor
hockey or soccer football or you know
run or throw the shot put all these
other things play basketball was a big
one wrestling as well we not only
learned those things we learned the
traits that go into good sportsmanship
and not everybody succeeded in that but
he was able to teach that whereas the
other coach engaged in in bullying
behavior as I mentioned encouraged it
and it really made a lot of people
miserable including the people who were
at the top of his pecking order I can
actually look at life outcomes for these
different people you know based on like
Facebook and see that the people who had
this coach were turned out to be happier
on the average and the people who had
this coach turned out to be more
miserable on the average so boarding is
subordinating yourself to everybody
within a practice isn't necessarily what
MacIntyre is talking about it has to be
to the people who are actually the
master practitioners and who have some
other things going for them so there's
two other things that we need to talk
about here standards can be partly
embodied in
rules and in orders from from you know
the the superiors within the tradition
but only partly so and one of the things
that you learn as you progress within a
practice is when to make your own
judgment calls when you need to listen
to the rules and when you need to
abandon them
the other thing that MacIntyre points
out and I think that this example of the
coaches illustrates this very well is
that in order for a practice to be
sustainable in order for people to
develop there are these virtues that are
required within it he says we have to
accept as necessary components of any
practice with internal goods and
standards of excellence the virtues of
justice courage and honesty
without these sustaining the practice
not everything happens that should or
things can actually go quite astray so
we've got a dynamic connection here
between practices standards rules goods
and indeed certain types of virtues
you